del congreso de la república una semana
tres presidentes el congreso de perú ha
elegido a francisco sagasti de 76 años
como presidente provisional en un
intento de acabar con la creciente
crisis política del país la cual ha
derivado en intensas protestas y en la
muerte de dos manifestantes
sagasti ha dicho que el país necesita
hacerse serias preguntas
[Música]
[Aplausos]
es un momento de reflexión es un momento
para preguntarnos para inventar es un
momento para avanzar decididamente pero
la crisis política se desató la semana
pasada cuando el congreso impugnó y
destituyó al presidente martín vizcarra
bajo alegaciones de corrupción
vizcarra a quien niega los cargos se ha
enfrentado durante mucho tiempo a los
legisladores por su postura
anticorrupción y sus intentos de revocar
la inmunidad parlamentaria popular entre
muchos peruanos su destitución terminó
en protestas furiosas en las que mataron
a dos manifestantes su reemplazo
constitucional el antiguo jefe del
congreso manuel merino renunció de su
cargo a los cinco días con la
intensificación de las protestas dejando
a perú sin líder por 24 horas ahora a
francisco sagasti ha sido elegido para
liderar el congreso y por tanto el país
sagasti estar a la cabeza del gobierno
hasta finales de julio del año que viene
incluye las elecciones del próximo 11 de
abril